um i'll introduce myself first i am
jolok stevens i am a senior software
developer at anaconda
so this talk is about seeing the needles
and the haystack and i'll tell you what
that means in a second
a single data point selection for
billion point data sets
now uh this whole track here is about
getting insights from big data and if
you want to get insight to something a
good way to do that is to visualize it
if you just look at all your real
numbers of your gigabyte data sets you
probably won't really get much out of it
so
when it comes to visualizing these large
data sets you come up with quite a few
different challenges
you can try to visualize big data and
you do that as one task and then often
you switch to
smaller data sets as a separate task and
this is kind of an annoyance when
working with large data sets
so
as everyone here probably knows data is
cheap it's getting larger year by year
we're getting gigabytes terabytes you
know it just keeps growing and we still
need to see and understand our data and
gain insight into it
so gaining insight into data is is
getting more difficult because you have
more data to look at and
all sorts of things inside your data
might not be quite visible immediately
there's a lot of
places to hide different patterns and
different things that you might be
interested in
so some of the problems are
many plotting tools that we have route
nowadays do not work very well with big
data
many things work in the browser nowadays
but as soon as you get to 100 000 points
things start to struggle and then if you
have gigabytes you're probably going to
have trouble putting that into a browser
tab
another specific problem about
visualization is something called
overplotting
i'll show you an example in a second and
basically what it means is that you've
got too much data you have a high data
density and how do you visualize that
high data density every single pixel of
your screen is going to correspond to
huge numbers of data points which causes
uh problems in terms of actually
interpreting that data and that's the
key throughout the whole talk you need
to be able to interpret your data from
all levels from the zoomed out data
level where you can see everything down
to an individual data point
and another thing which is about
visualization specifically is about the
dynamic range of the data which means
when you have huge numbers of amounts of
data points often they cluster in
specific places in your in your space in
your high dimensional space and then
lots of places are sparse and there's
not much there and then there's these
points which are hot spots which have
all the data in them and you have this
huge dynamic range that you want to plot
so um since 2016 we've had a project
called data shader
how many people have heard of data
shader i'm just curious okay not so many
um
which is a project which is actually a
rasterizer which is designed for large
data sets so if you're interested in
data show to go to data.org and you'll
see some of the things we have so for
example this is the entire u.s census
now the u.s census is about 330 million
people lots of data for each person
there's a lot of data here and you get
one image and you can actually see all
the cities in the united states and so
on and so forth
furthermore you can zoom in and you can
use data share to do categorical plots
so you have ethnicity data in in the
census so each color is a different
ethnicity and here we can see manhattan
new york city
and you can do all sorts of pretty
things with data shader so you notice
that these are static plots so that's an
important point
so they're very pretty but you get
something which you can't really explore
you can just see the whole united states
what if you want to look at one city you
know
so
it rasterizes everything it turns
everything in a 2d histogram which is
the image on your screen
um you have a huge data range for
example think about how dense new york
city is compared to i don't know rural
ohio or something uh you'll see there's
a huge range of population densities to
think about and if you use a linear
color map you wouldn't see anything
interesting here not not really
um so what we do with datasheet is
something called uh histogram
equalization
essentially it's just a trick which
comes from
i think
photography or just image processing
whereby you use your color map very
efficiently to cover the distribution of
the data that you actually have
this is why we have a non-linear color
map here but you can really clearly see
all the structure spatially across the
united states here
so this is pretty it's it's nice but
it's a static image it's just a png um
and that's what data shader was in 2016.
so this is great but yeah we want to
start exploring data so let's take a
data set so i've got something here
which is a herring data herring girl
data set so these are birds this is from
belgium from the coast of belgium where
we have about
2.42 million data sets data points
each one is a gps coordinate of a gull
and some of the data i'll show you so
here's the data frame here's the head of
the data frame longitude latitude the
temperature so they have sensors on
these uh little things that they have on
the gull the headings the direction that
the gull is heading um
the height above means sea level the
easting and the northern so east and
northing is just a different way of
expressing longitude and attitude you
may not be familiar with it but
okay so here's what it looks like with
data shader this is again what it would
look like in 2016 if you use the data
shader api
okay so you see there's structure here
you can see that you know there's
distributions that you know there's sort
of pathways where the girls fly and
sometimes they go along these routes and
they seem to be concentrating around
here but there's no context you can't
interact with it you can't zoom you
can't do much with this
this is just an rgb image it's a red so
it's just a typical like png image
so
what do we can we do with this program
starting in 2016 well you can view the
whole data set it this shader scales two
gigabytes as i said the sensors is huge
really large data sets will work and you
can use them in the browser in the
notebook
there's no over plotting and that's the
point i was making about this histogram
equalization uh you can actually see the
structure the data and i'll show you
what over plotting actually looks like
in a second and it's using the full
dynamic range which is the same kind of
thing it's about it's about um
uh
using this dynamic range and also the
other parting thing is the fact that
each
pixel is a bin and you're counting the
number of samples in that bin instead of
drawing like a circle for for each point
which you might do with a
more classic plotting program
so let's do some interactive plotting uh
this is using a um
a
project called hvplot which you can see
here on h3.holoverse.org
if you visit it and learn how to plot
with with this it gives you interactive
an interactive api just like dot plot
with with pandas data frames but it's
interactive
and what i'm going to do is i'm going to
down sample this so we had 2 million odd
points which is too much for the browser
let's make it um 12 000 so or so samples
now if we run this
um
we see what it looks like if you have a
large for the browser data set but not
really a large data set and you can see
that you got a lot of trouble there you
have a solid blue here you can't see
what's going on right uh what you can do
of course is zoom in
you can do a pan zoom
you can get closer and then you can
start hovering on these points you can
pan around you have all this
interactivity you can actually start
diving into the data from the zoomed out
view all the way down to an individual
point but it's not the whole data it's a
subset the data you've missed
you know there's like 95 percent of the
data is not here or even more actually
is that right anyway um so what we've
gained here is things like panning
zooming using a tile server so you have
a background now you can actually see
the map uh the actual coastline of
belgium instead of just this white
background
and you get inspection where you can
hover on this and see the data of each
single row in this data frame
that's great but again it's not the
whole data you're missing out all this
context
okay so
what we want to do now is start to
improve on this situation start taking
these two worlds the big data world
which you can do with data shader
visualization and then the smaller world
we've got interactivity with uh here
it's bokeh visualization using uh hv
plot
so um
what we have is in 2018 h3 plot added an
ability to start interacting with large
data sets so here's the same thing and
you can see you can recognize that from
here right the same structure overlaid
on this map
but now i can start to zoom in and as i
zoom in
it all adapts so i can still see my data
i can still see the hot spots i can
still
zoom all the way in so i can see
individual points
where each single point is a gps
coordinate of a gull at that time
so this is really nice this is really
really great you can um
you know start to actually see the
structure and zoom in so you've got the
context but what you've lost are the
things i talked about earlier you can't
do that inspection thing for example uh
that's gone um so you've gained some
things you've lost other things still
even with this newer
api from hp plot
okay
so um yes it's the whole data set no
there's over plotting i mean you can see
the structure much nicer than you could
with this plot when you're especially
when you're zoomed out you can't tell
what it is
um
you're using the full dynamic range
because it's using these rgb images uh
from data shader which are using this
histogram equalization
method
um but you can pan as
you saw me panning around and you can
zoom and you have a tile server but what
you don't have is a color bar and you
don't have the ability to inspect the
points
okay
so
the reason this is happening partially
is because you're using this non-linear
color map which is a very unusual thing
for most plotting programs um which is
why it's actually an rgb image because
you have to turn it into colored pixels
and then push it to the browser and then
display it because side you can't
actually uh use that information with a
sort of linear color map like you might
normally do
so what you what we really want to do is
push
the actual aggregates which is the
actual counts of how many um how many
samples on each single pixel uh to the
browser and then color map it on the
browser this is a special feature which
uh we've been working on and adding so
this is what happens when you use this
um normally it's called rasterize it's
pushing
the sort of um counts to the browser and
you can see this if i zoom in
you can see
for example how many um
you can see for example there's like 357
samples from seagulls in that pixel that
i'm hovering over but that's not the
actual data that i started with this is
a just an aggregate it's like a
histogram it's account
um and also you've noticed the color
map's gone strange and that's because i
don't have this histogram equalization
i'm just using a log color map if i if i
use linear it's going to be worse i'll
quickly just switch it to linear
useless right all the seagulls are
basically in this tiny point here and
you can't see anything with linear you
can sort of see a little bit of log but
it's nowhere near as good as what we had
a little bit earlier right
okay so
yes using this way of using data shader
you
gain a little bit you get some sort of
inspection but it's not really what we
want
you've got color bar now as you can see
it's a log color bar which which i said
was missing earlier um but you don't
have the full dynamic range because we
don't have this histogram equalization
okay so we're getting closer
and this is a newer stuff this is from
about a year ago so i'm still
considering that fairly new
since bokeh 2.2
bokeh has added this support for
histogram equalization
so what this means is we can now do this
and we now have this color bar which you
can see it's not it's kind of a strange
color bar if you look closely right and
you'll see it's even strange when i
start zooming in
you can see it's dynamically updating
it's kind of an odd color about
interpret if you just look at the color
bar but if you look at the image you can
see it's very clearly showing you the
structure of the data right
i can keep zooming in i can do box zooms
i can get all the way in and now i have
my full dynamic range my full ability to
zoom in down to an individual point
we're getting really really close to
being able to treat large data and small
data in the same way in the context of a
visualization
okay so here's the little table again
whole data set no overplotting full
dynamic range panning zooming tiles
color bar
but no inspection so we're still missing
one last thing that we want if you want
to go all the way from our gigabytes
down to one single row on our data frame
and that's the inspection tool
so uh before i show you how how that's
going to be done i will mention that um
since 2021 there's actually matplotlib
support to to some degree not not
everything supports the same way with hp
plot or data shader
but you can actually start using this
tool which is part of data shader to
actually use matplotlib
based uh histogram equalization panning
zooming
you have those features at least with
with this new feature in matplotlib and
data shader
i just wanted to throw some applause in
there not just show you bokeh
okay
so
we have almost everything we want and as
i said we want to be able to inspect
individual points
in our you know gigabytes of data
so what we have is a way to
look at this data but we want to be able
to
think about it in a way that we can
actually look hover on a single point
and actually see what's in that data
point
so
here i'm going to switch apis before
using hp plot which is based on holo
views and it's a nice easy api you just
use dot plot and so on
but
if but because it's based on holo views
we can actually use directly to see some
of these newer features or some of these
more advanced features this is a new
thing again it's about a year old
where what we can do is is using a
different api we can get ourselves the
same kind of little um
tile server slice of belgium and the
coast and then using hollow views we can
now use um histogram equalization so
this is kind of exactly what we just saw
i'm not showing anything new here it
behaves the same way it's just using a
different api
so it's the same same thing effectively
as what you just saw but using hollow
views we can now take the last step
right uh with this operation which is
called inspect
we can now overlay it and you'll see
what that means in such a way we can get
our hover back so now you see a little
circle and you can see the values
and i can see my whole data set where i
don't know anything about this data just
find out where these goals are
on the coast the whole data now i can
start zooming in i can do box zooms
i can do scroll zooms
i can pan around i can really interact
and now i can actually go all the way
down and you can see these are like
piers along the coast right you can
actually see the individual piers and
where these girls have been you can zoom
in and now
you can take a single point out of all
your data and say now i know exactly the
temperature it was 30 celsius on that
day on that time at that
point in time where that
data point was taken and measured and
recorded
so this is the needle in the haystack
right there's the haystack and what i
just showed you was the needle
okay so now we actually filled out our
entire
table of features we would like to be
able to interact with big data and small
data in the same way and
use the same kind of tools for
understanding our data regardless of the
size right same kind of insights you can
gain
both levels you just zoom out if you
want to see everything zoom in if you
want to see something specific
okay so i won't go into this in in
detail but um part of what we do um
anaconda as part of the holidays group
which you can visit on hollovis.org
which is using a lot of the tools i kind
of mentioned at least h3 hollow views
and data shader params in the background
you don't need to think too much about
it but it's there
is create a dashboard um you don't
actually need to
to look at the code too much you can see
it's like a couple of lines of code
and when you do this
you can actually serve it as a dashboard
it's using bokeh server and it's using
all the features we just talked about
and hopefully i might need to restart
let's see
i might need to restart this uh no
so back and everything i just did in the
notebook is now a dashboard which you
could deploy put it on um on a url you
can share with your colleagues and they
can also gain the same sort of insights
that you get with your large data sets
all the way down to individual points
and and the thing that's really powerful
about this is you will see things in
your data that you never knew were there
you will you will have missed things
with other tools whereas if you use this
kind of approach you will see patterns
and things will say what's that you'll
be able to zoom in and find out what it
is
and i might be able to give a quick
example of that in a second
okay so that's the dashboard
um there's more to this than what i've
shown you this is kind of the overview
of all the different things you can do
you can inspect you can use histogram
equalization but we're doing other
things too for example uh we're working
right now on curves and time series
where the initiator can actually do time
series uh and what we have is like lots
of i don't know could be neuroscience
where you've got voltages from neurons
that you're measuring or
stock graphs it could be all sorts of
different things there are time series
and then you can uh
basically use the same kind of thing of
selecting uh individual points or
individual traces as it is in this case
out the whole thing so this is a work in
progress that's not available yet
um
but we're working on it and we want to
also try and make this kind of
ability available at the h3 plot level
so you can just do something like
inspect equals true
in the call and then it'll be available
with a very easy api you won't need to
use holoviews directly
so i want to show you some really cool
demos in the last few minutes i have
which are
one showing another feature which is
polygon rendering
um so let me see if okay so let me open
this
okay let's try this i had i had to shut
down a
thing earlier
okay so this is um polygons and the
difference of course is points versus
polygons i need to restart kernel error
um
if it doesn't work i'll switch the next
thing which is also even better in fact
okay so this is polygon so this is new
york city again except now we have the
shape of every building in new york city
so the outline the kind of not the floor
plan but maybe the
the contour of the outside of the
building so this takes a few seconds to
run and what you'll see is we're gonna
get another plot with data shader
okay that might be a bit slow
uh no no there we go it's sped up
okay
uh this is a kind of a pre-processing
step which helps optimize things further
um but it's only done once so once
you've done it everything is quite quick
um and now it should be putting up this
plot which is what i want to show you
where you can do the same thing hover on
individual buildings in new york city
and see what they are it might take a
second to appear
there we go
okay so if i zoom in i'm somewhere i
don't know i guess it's brooklyn
somewhere uh zoom in datashed is doing
all the polygon uh it's actually
normally faster than this this is a
remote instance um it'll show up the
polygons and then you'll be able to see
the hover
i'll give it two seconds
come on
uh okay it's i have it locally but i'm
not gonna try oh it's coming up
okay i'll come back to it and show you
at the end um another really really cool
one oh there we go i'll just about
switch away
um now we have these different colored
buildings these are categories of
building like houses of worship schools
churches that kind of thing and i can
hover on one and see what kind of what
the name of the building is what kind of
building it is
okay and the last thing i want to show
you is um the really big data so this is
called ship traffic this is called ais
and it's collected by the coast guard in
the u.s
of all the
something like the seagulls the gps
pings of ships that are floating around
the u.s first i'll show you the static
images and they're very pretty these are
um i think there's 200 million yes 200
million data points uh here and there's
a lot of data lots of columns as well so
it's actually more than more than that
you can see all these different stripes
you can zoom in to vancouver you can
zoom into new york and see the patterns
of ship planes in new york
really cool stuff in the gulf coast
where you've lots of oil drilling i
guess
fishing boats which do these little
circles which you can spot
and
yeah there's lots of really pretty
pictures here
and of course you can then do
categorical so you can actually classify
it by the different types of ship
different colors for each different type
of ship
fishing ships um oil tankers and so on
so forth uh mississippi delta
um
and i think there's a color key there's
lots of these pretty pictures
here we go so here we go cargo fishing
ships passenger ships towing ships and
so on um
and
finally um
i might need to restart
uh fine i'll try i'll try my luck with
the deployment um
i have a live version of this that i
hope i can pull up in time so
um
so meanwhile while that's coming up um
any questions so far
q a in a second yup sure okay so in that
case i will actually check if there's
anything more to say and then i'll
switch to it okay so everything you've
seen is actually downloadable from this
link
um
anaconda.orgpy's project so this is
something called an icon project which
captures all my dependencies on on
datasheet h we plot everything into a
single reproducible unit and it's called
needles in the haystack and from that
you can actually run
the same thing that i've uh just shown
you
um
wait for that to come up there we go so
this is those 200 million data points
it's again zoomed in a bit um
and what we see again are the same
categories of fishing ships uh with the
data shader plot right here
and
what i've got is by default this ship
right here this is called the polar
resolution
uh and you can have a picture because uh
because you can actually hook up
callbacks and things um which let you so
for example hit web api get the picture
of the ship based on the name or
actually the unique vessel identifier
which i think is the mms if i remember
correctly
and then you have
pictures of the ships in this pixel that
have clicked
um so here we've got these these two
ships and if i click somewhere else i
should be able to pick up another ship
um
it takes a second there we go another
ship
doesn't seem to have a name this ship
and that does happen in this data set
and of course i can zoom in and keep
keep doing this thing picking individual
gps transponder pings
out of 200 million of these pings and
then find out exactly what i'm looking
for again it's the idea of this needle
in in the haystack
okay
and
i think that's it
yeah
[Applause]
thank you very much we will start with
the q a session right now
so the first question is what are some
data format optimizations you can do to
feed to feed data to hvplot efficiently
yes so um if you start with something
like a csv you have to pass the csv it's
not not the best format
the thing we generally try to use is
park a we find the parquet format to be
quite efficient
you can start using things like dask if
you have really large data sets and
parquet and so on so forth
there's also a project called spatial
pandas and i think there's going to be a
new project that's migrating to a
geo i can't this is geopandas yeah
whereby we have
optimized formats which are actually
spatially indexed which means if you're
doing a map
everything's got spatial locality and
you can do some clever tricks to
essentially have fast indexing into a
large data set by using the fact that
it's uh you're looking at a small
portion of the earth and you can just
sort of cull a huge amount of data sets
just by the the indices in the spatial
index so we have these
extra things you have to do to optimize
the data
to make this work really really well but
it does work even if you don't have
optimized data for fairly large data
sets but if you really really want to
push it there are more tricks you can
always add to get even more performance
out of it okay thank you like the next
question is what is the biggest data set
size the hollow whiz toolkit can render
oh good question um i think the census
might be
one of the largest um that i i think
we've ever done
um
which i can't i
i don't actually i'm sorry i don't have
to hand the size of the census data set
it's it's big it's it's really really
big um and i would say that in theory
there's no real limit if you have a
cluster and you have dusk and you can
distribute your workload
you can you can do it on any size as
long as you have the ram across enough
machines and you're using dusk you can
the sky's the limit there's no limit
if you mean interactive usage on a
single machine then you're going to be
limited by the amount of ram on your
laptop essentially so yeah okay thank
you
next question is um is sub sampling done
in the back oh wait
stop walting
it's sub sampling done in the background
when wider area is selected and the
actual loading is done when zooming
um so for the way data shader works it's
actually interesting that by default it
actually does a full part of the whole
data set every time you render anything
these optimization it uses number behind
the scenes which really can speed things
up hugely and uh there are these extra
optimizations we could add but we've not
really found need for them we can
actually do a full pass to the whole
data set
that even if you're zoomed in
we actually for data shader uh we're
rendering the whole thing you know the
whole data so we're doing full pass
where every single sample adds to each
pixel and that's the thing i didn't
actually mention which is this is really
scientifically accurate on top of
everything every single person in the
united states is contributing some time
tiny amount to this plot right every
single sample counts because it gets
bind into a histogram and that's a
scientifically accurate way of actually
presenting the data
so you do a pass to the whole data you
get a scientifically accurate
output and even if you zoomed in we're
doing that with a full pass each time so
so those extra optimizations do exist
but we're not actually using them and
we've not found much need for them yet
so
yeah okay um can you add new points
updating as existing charts
um
yes yes you can uh yes you can um you
probably have to do a little bit more
work you need to probably use hollow
views and something called dynamic map
whereby you could generate the data data
rasterized plots with data shader for
each zoom level so you basically get
some information about the bounds the
viewport that you're looking at you pass
it initially you render it and you have
a chance that point to get that data
from anywhere you could get it from a
database it could be updating there
could be more points appearing it could
be live all of that's possible yeah
not possible i don't think
maybe with the streams api'd have to
check but i don't think offhand that
it's possible the h3plot api but it's
definitely possible with the holovis
tools as a whole
is it possible to define other
aggregations for each pixel or groups of
pixels colonel excellent question and
the answer is yes
we have
the count is one of them which you just
saw where you have the count of the
pixels but we have other statistics we
can do you can do the max for example
you can do
um i think a mean right you can take the
mean of all the samples in that pixel
the different aggregations we can do um
and oh yeah we have a selection of them
you can check them out on datasheet.org
uh can you export the images for use in
other programs um web-based mapping
frameworks
oh okay i mean like tile servers maybe i
don't know so um
so you can of course export to pngs and
and pill pill comes with data shader for
sort of simple image output
to do a tile server we've had projects
based on this before it's possible i
don't know what the status is in terms
of being public and being usable but we
have worked or had projects where we
wanted to use data shader to have a tile
server where you could
put it online and then just like google
earth you could zoom into anything you
want with a web just with a url yeah
does multi-point selection also work
with the most powerful overlay solution
okay uh another good question so
uh when you have overlays that's
normally when you'd have categorical
like when you had the multiple
ethnicities in new york city or the
different types of shipping vessels we
want different colors that's an overlay
um
right now i think um if you use
datasheet itself use the datashader uh
operation which gives you the rgb
uh which means that you have all that
information in data shader but to get it
out i think at the whole of use level
right now it's it's it's separate it's a
separate pass of data shader for each
each one of those
uh things especially if you want to use
the inspection and and uh tools i've
been talking about
so but that's a good question something
that we have in mind and we're thinking
about
okay next question is why did it require
a new api to add inspection support
uh just time really it's just
development time we know what to do we
know how to do it
it's an open source project so we
our main main jobs aren't always just
working on open source we work with
clients and other things so we work in
open source when we can and when we have
the time we will add we'll add this we
know exactly what to do we just haven't
got around to it that's that's all yeah
okay perfect awesome thank you very much
[Applause]